am I the wizard man well let's see did I
single-handedly slay the twin ice
dragons of powder Veil Lake yes I did am
I the wizard man well let's see did I
single-handedly defend the castle of
calor from an undead army yes I did am I
the wizard man well let's see did I
transform myself into a giant in order
to single-handedly rescue the princess
and her fiance from a hive of angry
Thunder Titans who wanted to put them in
a goddamn stew yes I did am I the wizard
man well let let's see even though I'm
not a blacksmith did I Forge The Arc
blade because I'm the only person in the
realm who can channel that much fell
energy without burning to a crisp yes I
did so yeah I'm the [__] wizard
man now who the [__] are
you he knows who he is do you you ever
touch my staff again I'll break your
[__] hands kich